[Musique]
mon sens à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
emmanuel macron à l'offensive le leader
dans marche attaque françois fillon un
homme de peu de valeur selon lui il
était l'invité de notre matinale
spéciale à territoire d'infos en cause
la publication d'un mot manuscrit à
l'occasion des débats sur la déchéance
de nationalité
on en parle à dans un instant suite de
notre reportage de notre série consacrée
à la campagne sur le terrain
nous avons suivi philippe poutou le
candidat du npa il était tiers en
meeting à reims celui qui est en hausse
dans les sondages depuis sa prestation
télévisée remarquer veut amplifier le
mouvement
les pouvoirs publics face aux
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est le
thème d'un colloque qui s'est tenu
aujourd'hui au sénat quelle définition
au niveau européen comment s'en protéger
que proposent les prétendants à l'elysée
dans leurs programmes sur cet enjeu de
santé publique le débat à suivre
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir en direct à cette émission sur
twitter hashtag présidentielle 360
à douze jours du premier tour aller clip
de campagne des onze candidats ont été
dévoilés hier pendant trois minutes ils
doivent permettre aux électeurs d'en
savoir plus sur les programmes des
personnalités politiques en lice dans la
course à l'elysée revue de détail avec
héloïse grégoire la cuvée des clips de
campagne 2010 est est arrivé depuis
lundi les onze candidats ont le droit de
faire leur publicité des spots qui
répondent à des exigences très encadrée
comme l'exercice est extrêmement
contraint par la réglementation
on peut pas appeler son copain steven
spielberg et lui dire fais moi mon clip
de campagne
c'est avec les outils de l'état les
budgets de l'état qu'on doit ré
lisez dans un cadre contraint ce clip
audio visuel donc l'exercice étant
tellement cadres et qu'on peut très
rarement être créatif une minute trente
pour les petits clips et 3 minutes 30
pour les longs formats
à chacun son style chaque spot
correspond à l'univers du candidat le
clip de dupont aignan va être très
emphatique très premier degré le clip de
macrobe très scolaire très premier degré
aussi le clip de mélenchon est très
démonstratif avec un peu commun youtuber
ces passages face caméra hamon se
cherche et ça se voit aussi dans son
clip c'est très longue de la musique à
des moments il faudrait fins et très
bizarrement conçu ces on sait pas très
bien où il est donc ça représente
d'heure la campagne du candidat
certains veulent convaincre quand
d'autres sont dans la provocation
c'est dans sa stratégie c'est dans son
rôle d'être un petit peu le trublion le
bouffon de la campagne et d'agiter des
choses c'est pas trés crédibilisant je
pense que ça ne va pas les faire gagner
de voix c'est un tout petit peu dommage
parce que c'est pas vraiment un clip
politique
ces spots sont de véritable boîte à
outils de la campagne mais leur impact
reste limitée c'est vieillot
c'est mal monte souvent ou en tout cas
c'est pas très original
les ressorts qui sont utilisés sont d'un
classicisme qu'on ne peut pas se se se
départir de quasiment du voisin cette
année plus le droit au drapeau tricolore
ni à la marseillaise
le csa interdit l'instrumentalisation de
ces symboles regonflé par le débat
télévisé qui l'a fait connaître
outre-atlantique grâce à un article dans
le new york times philippe poutou se
voit pousser des ailes dans cette
campagne
créditée de 2,5 pour cent d'intentions
de vote dans les sondages le candidat du
nouveau parti en kit anti capitaliste on
chaîne allait réunion publique en se
revendiquant d'extrême gauche nous
l'avons suivi à reims reportage de
compte un chalmé et samia de sheer le
npa à reims c'est un groupe de seulement
trois militants et pourtant ce soir ils
ont le sourire la salle louée à reims
peut accueillir 300 personnes et elle
s'annonce trop petit pour l'événement
ces derniers jours une nouvelle
dynamique est apparue autour de la
candidature de philippe poutou ans les
personnes
maintenant reconnaissent le nom de
philippe poutou se retourne vont venir
nous voir ils vont félicité philippe
poutou dire que ils donnent leur soutien
et voilà on a fait aussi des affichages
le soir où plusieurs personnes sont
venus nous rencontrer ce qui se faisait
pas avant
devant les journalistes de plus en plus
nombreux à ses meetings il le reconnaît
c'est sa prestation au débat télévisé à
onze candidats qui a fait la différence
il ya un avant et un après c'est
difficile de dire de dire que non ça
dans la rue c'est sûr que c'est assez
énorme
c'est intéressant c'est ça discute et ça
reflète aussi le niveau de colère qui
peut y avoir quand même
mine de rien la le ras-le-bol de tout ça
de ce monde politiciens de ce monde tel
qu'il est et donc voilà ça ça traduit ça
est bien pour nous ça fait du bien parce
que c'est ce qu'on recherche et ça nous
rassure quand on le voit devant nous un
débat qui place philippe poutou dans une
nouvelle dynamique et qui permet de
remplir les salles la semaine dernière à
montpellier et à rouen et hier soir à
reims ils sont nombreux à vouloir
assouvir leur curiosité j'ai trouvé
qu'il était assez efficace au début j'ai
été assez surprise par ces interventions
et du coup je me sais que ça pourrait
être sympathique de venir le voir
en réalité la plupart des candidats on
les attend on attend leurs points de vue
on sait à peu près ce qu'ils vont dire
philippe poutou c'est quelqu'un qui
vient pas du même milieu que les autres
et du coup on attend de voir un peu
comment il va il va prendre sa place
dans le milieu politique
une heure de discours pendant laquelle
le candidat anti capitaliste revient sur
les fondamentaux de sa campagne smic à
1700 euros nets dénonciation des
politiques d'austérité ou encore
désarmement de la police philippe poutou
se revendique d'être d'extrême gauche
le fond du problème c'est que là le
système capitaliste il est entre les
mains de des possédants entre les mains
des riches qui eux décide de ce qu'il
faut il décide de ce qu'il faut produire
de comment il faut produire et den-yih
fixe les règles et c'est eux qui disent
voilà c'est comme ça et pas autrement
mais l'on dit si ça peut être autrement
avec une ambition avouée à demi mot pour
le candidat du npa réaliser un aussi bon
score qu'olivier besancenot et ses 4 %
en 2002
6-5 ap tom tranier nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau bonsoir tam avec vous nos
devoirs et bien procédé à cette rubrique
quotidienne maintenant de fact iqlim on
va passer à la loupe les propos d'
emmanuel macron il était l'invité de
notre matinale spéciale territoire d'un
faux j'en propose toute une de l'écouter
il a perdu tout repère éthique moreau de
comportement tout repère et donc
françois fillon est un homme de peu de
valeur
c'est la conclusion de gentilles et
enfin sur le fond de quoi s'agit-il
il me dit vous venez sur mes positions
sur la déchéance de nationalité c'est à
dire qu'ils étaient contre et j'avais
rappelez vous annoncer que j'étais
contre je lui confirme et je lui dis oui
j'y suis déjà je ne rejoins pas j'y suis
déjà j'étais contre la défiance françois
fillon un homme de peu de valeur qu est
ce qui a suscité la colère des manuels
macron thann oui on a entendu une colère
qui remonte en fait à un épisode qui
s'est suite il ya deux jours dimanche le
candidat de la droite dévoile aux
journalistes une anecdote encombrante
pour emmanuel macron françois fillon
raconte qu'il a échangé des sms avec le
ministre de l'économie de février 2016
on est alors en plein débat très houleux
sur la déchéance de nationalité
françois fillon aurait alors écrit à
macron une nouvelle fois vous venez sur
mes positions jusqu'où irez-vous réponse
d'emmanuel macron j'y suis déjà
c'est ce qu'a admis emmanuel macron ce
matin tan oui mais problème hier face au
dévoilement de cet échange censée
montrer l'inconstance du candidat dans
marché bien emmanuel macron a répliqué
françois fillon a un problème avec la
vérité je n'ai jamais échangé de sms
avec lui sur la déchéance de nationalité
sauf que les deux hommes ont bien
échanger sur ce sujet même si ce n'était
pas pareil c'est maintenant ils ont
échangé sur des bristols à en-tête de
l'assemblée nationale dont techniquement
pas par des sms mais ça ne change pas
grand-chose à la faire et on peut
d'ailleurs découvrir l'ensemble du mot
écrit par un emmanuel macron de sa main
sur le site du figaro ce matin et on y
lit monsieur le premier ministre cheikh
françois en fait j'y suis déjà sans
doute je poursuivrai sur ce chemin car
c'est le seul que je connais voyons-nous
bien avoue emmanuel macron effectivement
alors que françois fillon et son
entourage face fuite et un ce message
personnel dans un journal à moins de
deux semaines du premier tour
pas très courtois c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'était un petit peu la
guerre de la campagne que montre cette
affaire tam et bien d'abord que françois
fillon ils conservent très bientôt les
petits mots qui lui sont adressés
ensuite que des changes entre emmanuel
macron et françois fillon a bien existé
enfin qu'en février 2016 lors du débat
sur la déchéance françois fillon
emmanuel macron sont effectivement sur
les mêmes positions je rappelle qu'à
l'époque et bien emmanuel macron n'est
pas du tout à l'aise avec cette mesure
françois fillon lui il est opposé à la
déchéance de nationalité mais parce
qu'il estime que c'est un rafistolage
constitutionnel au passage je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui il est favorable à la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
français qui partirait sur des terrains
comme la syrie l'irak pour des actes
terroristes alors emmanuel macron à
celle vraiment été inconstants et il en
faute puisque c'est ce que veut
d'ailleurs démontré françois fillon et
bien ce qu'on peut constater en tout cas
c'est qu'il n'a pas dit les mêmes choses
en 2016 à quelques mois quelques
semaines même d'intervalle
regardez 6 janvier 2016 emmanuel macron
donne une interview au monde il déclare
que la déchéance de nationalité c'est
une mesure symboliquement importante et
qu'il est pleinement solidaire de la
politique gouvernementale
deux semaines plus tard le 20 janvier
voilà ce qu'il se dit sur le plateau de
bfm écouter on ne peut pas considérer
qu'on traite le problème qu'on traite le
mal en l'excluant de la communauté
nationale
oui on ne peut pas traiter le mal en
l'excluant de la communauté nationale
je précise toutefois que dans l'ensemble
l'allocution qu'il avait alors était
plutôt loyal à françois hollande mais
tout de même y glisse cette pique à la
fin et puis le 9 février encore quelques
semaines plus tard il enfonce un peu
plus le coût en dise le clou en disant
son inconfort philosophique avec la
place que le débat a pris et puis
dernière référence en date au mois de
septembre 2016 il a alors quitté le
gouvernement
son entourage fait savoir qu'il a quitté
le gouvernement notamment parce qu'il
était en désaccord avec françois
hollande sur la déchéance de nationalité
en résumé et bien on peut dire qu'il
maniait macro et bien opposées à la
déchéance de nationalité mais c'est
beaucoup beaucoup plus clair depuis
qu'il n'est plus au gouvernement
merci beaucoup thème pour ce décryptage
on en vient à présent dans l'actualité
du sénat avec ce colloque sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens
après un rapport de la haute assemblée
sur cet enjeu de santé publique pourtant
peu présent dans la campagne flora
sauvage
un seul inscrit dans son programme
benoît hamon veut l'interdiction pure et
simple des perturbateurs endocriniens
pour lui la france ne doit pas attendre
les injonctions de la commission
européenne il faut une loi nationale
comme pour le bisphénol a sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens sur les
pesticides
là il ne faudra pas avoir la main qui
tremble dans ce domaine jean luc
mélenchon nathalie arthaud philippe
poutou françois asselineau et nicolas
dupont aignan veulent les réglementent
est très sévèrement plus nuancé emmanuel
macron veut qu'une interdiction
progressive au cas par cas
françois fillon préfère s'en tenir au
statu quo il propose de réécrire le
principe de précaution la candidate du
front national marine le pen estime que
seule une sortie de l'union européenne
permettra de nous protéger des
perturbateurs endocriniens
enfin jacques cheminade et jean lassalle
pense qu'il est encore trop tôt pour se
positionner sur la question est pour
nous éclairer sur les anges de ces
perturbateurs endocriniens ces
pesticides le bisphénol les phtalates et
leurs conséquences sur la santé françois
veillerette m'a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonsoir vous êtes directeur et
porte-parole de générations futures vous
assistez à ce colloque du sénat on vient
de le voir on n'en parle pas beaucoup
dans la campagne à part peut-être avec
benoît hamon est ce que vous diriez une
prise en compte tardive de saison 11e en
matière de santé publique en ce qui
concerne les perturbateurs dans d'autres
sur la question des perturbateurs
endocriniens on a quand même une réelle
progression de la prise de conscience de
la dangerosité il ya quelques années
personne ne savait ce que c'était on
vous demandait toujours de répéter des
quoi les perturbateurs quoi aujourd'hui
quand on regarde des sondages part
grandissante de la population qui
connaît la majorité de ses produits et
on voit que le personnel politique
commence à se saisir de cette question
là ils viennent des candidats éminents
qui en font des points programmatiques
important donc il ya également pendant
le même temps des législations
européennes qui ont évolué sur la
question et j'entendais marine le pen
dire qu'il fallait sortir de l'ordre
pour ça c'est n'importe quoi c'est
justement aller première législation au
monde qui prévoit d'exclure les
perturbateurs endocriniens sont les
législations européennes qui vont
justement pouvoir permettre de protéger
des pans entiers de la population
d'assurance sur un problème de
définition notamment au niveau européen
formulée alors
il ya effectivement des règlements sur
les pesticides et les biocides sont des
familles de produits chimiques qui
prévoit d'exclure les perturbateurs
endocriniens dont ces grandes familles
de produits le problématique c'est qu'il
faut définir des critères scientifiques
pour dire ce qu'on va exclure
est ce qu'on ne va pas exclure et là je
dirais la somme de lobby chimiques sont
rentrés par la fenêtre un petit peu de
la commission européenne pour influencer
les décisions de la commission open j'ai
retardé son action est pour l'a poussé à
proposer des critères scientifiques qui
sont très faibles qui en fait ne vont
pas permettre de réellement retiré tous
les produits qu'ils demanderaient à
l'être est ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
toutes les conséquences sur la santé que
peuvent avoir ces perturbateurs
endocriniens
alors on ne connaît pas tous aujourd'hui
des perturbateurs endocriniens est à peu
près rendez vous contre seulement 30 ans
qu'on sait que ça existe et on a pris
conscience de la réalité des effets des
perturbateurs endocriniens
d'après des études sur les animaux en
amérique du nord et puis il ya 20 ans va
commencer à voir qu'on avait aussi des
phénomènes similaires chez chez l'homme
j'ai l'espèce humaine et donc on ne sait
pas tout mais on s'est quand même un
certain nombre de choses et on sait
maintenant qui joue un rôle absolument
fondamental dans la parution de maladies
chroniques aussi importante que certains
cancers des problèmes de reproduction
des problèmes de malformations de
l'appareil génital des problèmes qui
touchent le métabolisme ou des maladies
neurodégénératives
si c'est le foetus qui est exposée
pendant la grossesse houle
le jeune enfant pendant les premiers
mois de sa vie donc c'est une des
avancées scientifiques qui ont
révolutionné d'ailleurs la perception de
la conception de la toxicologie
puisqu'avant pensais que c'était la dose
qui allait forcément faire le poison
maintenant on s'aperçoit que c'est
davantage la terre d'exposition qui va
en fait programmées ou non selon qu'on
est exposée ou pas certaines substances
à certains moments des maladies qui vont
apparaître plus tard dans la vie
saljic bonsoir vous êtes cette
directrice des affaires scientifiques à
la ffb eac la fédération des entreprises
de la beauté vous assistez également à
ce colloque au sénat est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la législation et protège
suffisamment les consommateurs de ces
perturbateurs endocriniens qui
pourraient être contenues dans certains
produits cosmétiques un bon soir ce
colloque était très intéressant on a vu
les oppositions entre les industriels
les ong et la difficulté des politiques
d'arriver à cerner un problème qui a
acquis un contour scientifique encore
floues
pour lequel il ya une réelle
préoccupation de l'opinion publique est
tout à fait légitime puisque la
perturbation endocrinienne existe est en
revanche un cadre réglementaire qui est
difficile à bâtir alors ce qui concerne
spécifiquement les produits cosmétiques
la réglementation européenne est une
réglementation extrêmement protectrice
elle a été amplifiée en 2013 donc il ya
quatre ans elle prévoit une évaluation
de la sécurité du produit et de chacune
des substances qui composent le produit
est née aujourd'hui qu'ils sont présents
dans les lots d'oran à danser leur règne
dans les champs et ça on peut pas à la
fois dire qu'on ne sait pas ce que c'est
on ne sait pas définir sur un plan
réglementaire ce qu est un perturbateur
endocrinien et dire qu'ils sont présents
dans mon talent et elle traite une liste
de l'ufc que choisir qui a été interrogé
pendant le colloque pour savoir quelle
était l'origine de sa liste en fait elle
était incapable de répondre de manière
précise des listes circulent de toutes
origines
ces listes ont été enfin le comité
scientifique pour la sécurité des
consommateurs en europe qui est
l'instance scientifique qui contrôle la
sécurité des ingrédients cosmétiques a
récusé la plupart des substances qui
sont mises en avant dans cette liste
comme étant des perturbateurs
endocriniens et dit qu'elle était sûre
donc on est c'est exactement la
situation dans laquelle on est sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens avec
dépositions d'experts qui disent les
avis qu'ils ont des avis contradictoires
et il nous peignons qu'il ne sait pas
très bien comment s'avère être sur cette
liste des composants indésirables qu'on
peut trouver dans des produits du
quotidien et des produits cosmétiques
est ce qu'elle est valable cette liste
est ce qu'il faut et bien se méfier de
ces produits les différentes listes en
fonction du degré de certitude sur tel
ou tel produit mais je voulais reprendre
une partie ce qui a été dit aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas dire qu'on ne sait pas
définir ce qu'est un perturbateur
endocrinien on le sait d'ailleurs le msa
une définition il ya une définition
jusqu'à perturbateurs endocriniens la
question ce qui se pose en europe
c'est une question davantage politique
ça va où on va tracer la ligne de ce
qu'on va exclure alors ça se limite à
deux familles les pesticides et les
biocides pour l'instant nous demandent à
ce que ce soit pour vous si l'on exclut
toutes les familles de produits
chimiques c'est pas une question
scientifique c'est de la science
réglementaires ou est-ce qu'on trace la
ligne
il ya beaucoup de politique beaucoup d'
influence aussi des différents acteurs
notamment les acteurs économiques
mais au niveau scientifique on sait
aujourd'hui dire ce qui est un
perturbateur en rien une définition de
ms qui dit voilà toute substance ou
mélanges de substances qui va agir sur
le système hormonal et qui va induire
des effets néfastes chez un organisme
entier ou sa descendance donc c'était un
peu d'espacé défini sur telle ou telle
substance qu'on n'avait pas on pouvait
pas prendre de mesure parce qu'il n'ya
pas de définition qui est factuellement
faux il y en a une et compris au plus
haut niveau de l' oms au niveau
international non la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est que il faut est
d'accord sur une approche l'approchent
sur les pesticides et les biocides elle
est basée sur le danger c'est à dire que
le législateur et il a voulu faire en
sorte qu'on protège la santé publique
d'abord si on sait que la molécule à la
capacité d'induire un phénomène de
perturbation endocrinienne pouvons avoir
un effet néfaste pour l'homme
on n'attend pas d'être sûr à 100% en
faisant une évaluation du risque
classiques pour l'interdire il faut
l'interdire tout de suite sur des
caractéristiques propres durs de la
substance et ça c'est un réel progrès
pour la santé publique en europe et donc
en france un cas que préconisez-vous
ajustement de protéger les consommateurs
alors je pense que malheureusement le
débat mélange un tout petit peu les
choses
on est d'accord sur une définition de ce
qu'est un perturbateur endocrinien mais
une fois que vous avez discuté un
perturbateur endocrinien
vous n'avez pas défini de cadre
réglementaire la raison pour laquelle
les discussions s'éternisent au niveau
européen c'est d'abord d'une fin de ce
processus de lait bio s'il existe des
propositions manche en sept 2009 en
existe des propositions sur lesquelles
est évidemment on n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord parce que le sujet n'est
pas si simple que ça et une fois que
vous quand bien même ces propositions
serait adopté une fois que vous aurez à
conduire à l'interdiction de certains
produits ses cymbales
moi je ne peux pas vous dire à quel
produit sainteté conduire à la
traduction je ne sais pas c'est ça il ya
une différence entre dire je vais vous
expliquer je vais vous donner un exemple
vous pouvez dire un jour c'est un poison
parce que si vous la buse et vous
mourrez d'accord une fois que vous avez
dit ça vous n'avez pas dit quels sont
les poisons
vous comprenez la différence avant de
vous vous pouvez dire une substance
parce qu'on va appeler qu'il semble
ainsi de précaution vous savez de mme
alexander vous savez pas ou parce que
quand un animal la boit il en meurt
c'est pas du tout de cette caricature
est ce que je raconte mais c'est un bon
exemple
une fois vous avez dit ça et vous déjà
interdit toutes les substances qui font
que quand un animal
des bois il en heure vous n'avez pas dit
quelles sont les substances en question
le problème sur l'est aujourd'hui la
législation les problèmes à j-7 y soient
les perturbateurs endocriniens sont les
deux législations sur les pesticides et
sur les biocides et là le cadre il
existe le problème c'est l'absence de
code c'est que la commission européenne
n'a pas fait son travail elle aurait dû
définir des critères pour savoir ce
qu'on à l'exclure ou pas dès décembre
2013 elle a tellement été inactif
qu'elle était condamnée par la cour
européenne de justice pour inaction à la
demande de la suède
cette plainte avait des soutenue par la
france donc aujourd'hui c'est pas le
problème du 4 inexistant il existe pour
ces familles de produits
nous on souhaite qu'ils s'étendent
progressivement de manière horizontale
aux autres familles de produits
chimiques dans les cosmétiques et des
autres pour une raison de cohérence aux
organismes et ne font pas de politique
ou n'est une raisonnement si l'eau ils
sont exposés à des substances il faut
toutes les années de même année
d'ailleurs mené plusieurs actions groupe
points en testant justement sur certains
députés écologistes la présence de ces
perturbateurs endocriniens dans les
cheveux qu'on rêvait oui alors quand on
cherche on la trouvait à peu près la
moitié des substances qu on a recherché
donc l'idée c'est de montrer qu'il ya un
problème d'appréciation de la population
avec des produits qui pour le coup des
produits à la toxicité avérée je veux
dire on avait on avait des pcb on avait
des dioxines 1 avait des pesticides
connus pour leur toxicité et c est donc
ce type de travail sert à montrer que la
population entière est concernée
c'est pas quelques pour cent de la
population la population entière est
concernée à des degrés divers selon
l'environnement dans lequel elles visent
ni d'alimentation son métier etc
et donc c'est un problème sociétal qui
doit être perçue je me répète comme une
question positif parce que si on agit
sur la sécurité chimique en retirant
progressivement laissé substance du
marché on va agir dans une dans la
direction de l'amélioration de la santé
de la population et donc on va voir les
fantômes de statistiques s'améliorait
des dépenses publiques en termes
sanitaires également baissé donc ça tout
le monde et il ya intérêt y compris
l'industrie chimique qui va mettre de
nouveaux produits sur le marché
ce petit et je voulais dire que le la
vis aux cosmétiques a pas entendu cette
définition sur laquelle à ce cadre
législatif qui n'existe pas pour pour
prendre des mesures puisqu'il ya un
comité d'experts indépendants auprès de
la commission européenne qui ces
planches qui s'est penchée sur cette
question là et qui a rendu un avis
en 2014 qui fait référence pour dire que
ce le cadre réglementaire des produits
cosmétiques en europe était un cadre qui
lui permettait tout à fait de gérer la
question de l'éventuelle cartu relation
endocriniennes des ingrédients
cosmétiques et donc ce comité
scientifique
il n'a pas besoin que les substances
soient classés par une autre
réglementation pour les examiner et donc
il a rappelé dans cet avis qui l'avait
examiné un certain nombre de substances
et qui en avait conclu qu'elle n'était
pas perturbateurs endocriniens
parce qu'il faut pas croire que toutes
les substances sont forcément
perturbatrices endocriniennes il y en a
qui ne le sont pas et donc cette année
est important que cet avis dix mois
certes j'ai pas de cadre réglementaire
spécifique mais donne tous les outils
pour savoir si les substances vous
éliminez un problème sociétal est ce que
vous pensez que les tous les ingrédients
sont finalement réunis pour un scandale
sanitaire avec des négligence de
certains états alors là pour le coup
c'est pas les états membres
individuellement qui sont mis en cause
c'est l'ensemble des élèves de l'europe
est qui qui doit prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent et appliqué d'ailleurs les
règlements caisses qui sont votées parce
que le problème là c'est pas que
n'existe pas de cadre pour les deux
familles de produits biocides pesticides
c'est que le règlement n'est pas
proprement appliquée et ça c'est la
commission européenne qui porte une
responsabilité ce n'est pas l'europe en
tant que tel on confond souvent tout
mais moi je suis de ceux qui croient que
sont pas uniquement les comités
d'experts qui font la politique au
niveau européen ce règlement sur les
pesticides et les biocides
effectivement les experts ont eu leur
mot à dire ils ont été entendus de
continue à l'être
mais ce sont les eurodéputés c'est la
commission et les états membres qui ont
leur mot à dire
il s'agit de la santé publique en europe
on va pas confié un uniquement un comité
d'experts la responsabilité de définir
la politique européenne en la matière
dans des familles de produits
effectivement chacun à sa place et son
rôle
il ya des gens qui doivent définir des
objectifs pour la société en termes
sanitaires
il ya des comités d'experts dont le
boulot est de dire leur opinion sur la
science et après on est ici au sénat
sont les élus qui prennent les décisions
j'étais en tout cas moi une conception
de travail public n ayant travaillé sur
cette question à travers le rapport des
sénateurs vasselle et financiers mais
aussi ce colloque merci anne dux merci à
vous françois veillerette on continue
cette émission michel grossiord va tout
de suite me rejoindre sur ce plateau
dans un instant les preuves de vie
spécial présidentiel au menu ce soir
trois invités mais oui campagne
officielle oblige il n'y a plus de
petits et de grands candidats enfin si
quand même en théorie il reste des
petits candidats dont deux qui seront là
tout à l'heure pour animer le débat
nathalie arthaud qui revient comme
candidate au nom de lutte ouvrière
et puis un nouveau cette année qu'on a
commencé à apprendre à connaître qui est
françois asselineau qui lui nous
garantit à coup sûr le fric site
et puis nous recevrons également nicolas
bay le secrétaire général du front
national pour parler de sa candidature
la de sa candidate marine le pen une
candidature qui semble un petit peu
plafonné en ce moment qui a trois
sondages qui ont été publiés cet après
midi et qui montre que marine le pen
certes est toujours en tête aujourd'hui
des suffrages mais qui semble quand même
connaître un trou d'air merci michel l
épreuve de vérité c'est donc à suivre en
direct à partir de 18h30 sur notre
antenne
en attendant retour sur les travaux du
sénat et cette déclaration commune des
parlements nationaux ce matin c'était à
l'initiative de la commission des
affaires européennes
elle souhaite poser les principes à
respecter avant toute renégociation de
la pac
reportage de yonathan der vaart quatre
parlementaires pour quatre pays de
l'union européenne réunis côte à côte
la france l'italie la pologne et
l'irlande ensemble ils affirment leur
soutien à la politique agricole commune
au moment où l'europe est remise en
cause
au royaume uni mais même dans notre
élection présidentielle réaffirmer le
sens d'une politique européenne forte
le sens où si des compromis des
constructions de politique commune en
faisant des concessions
c'est l'objet de la réunion aujourd'hui
d'ici fin 2010 est le système financier
de la pac sera négocié par la commission
européenne
ck pays les principaux producteurs
agricoles espère peser en amont dans les
négociations pour sauvegarder l'ensemble
du budget de la pac et organiser les
agriculteurs européens
on ne peut pas continuer à avoir d'un
côté une concentration des pouvoirs de
la grande distribution
je suis extrêmement crue avec quatre
cinq acheteurs et de l'autre côté à voir
s'ils voulaient des agriculteurs qui
sont en ordre dispersé mais pour
certains cet accord est trop
consensuelle on ne parle pas d'un
d'agroécologie on ne parle pas de
transition alors que c'est complètement
landre deux jours de son côté le
syndicat d entreprise coopérative
agricole soutient l'accord espère qu'il
ira plus loin
demain le revenu des agriculteurs c'est
les soutiens de la pac plus la vente de
leurs produits et la vente de leurs
produits doit monter en gamme et doit
être murray même rémunérateur qui ne
l'est aujourd'hui
avec ce texte le signal politique des
pays membres est clair le dernier mot
lui sera donnée par la commission
européenne
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition à suivre
l'épreuve de vérité spéciale
présidentielle 2010 est invité ce soir
nathalie arthaud françois asselineau et
nicolas bay secrétaire général du front
national à très bonne soirée à tous sur
public sénat
[Musique]
il